[Música]
nos encontramos con sergi high que es el
gobernador de la provincia del lugar y
también el director de la administración
militar de esta provincia que se
encuentra en medio de uno de los
principales combates que se libran
actualmente en ucrania muchas de sus
poblaciones ya están en control de las
fuerzas enemigas gobernador gracias por
estar comprados 24 hilo para empezar
cuál es la situación actual de su
provincia
la situación es difícil pero esto no es
sólo de hoy
esto sucede todos los días en la región
de lugares una de las razones es que
cuando comenzó la invasión a gran escala
por parte de rusia tuvimos que abandonar
un gran área de la región para poder
construir una línea de defensa y así
poder aguantar
y creemos que tomamos la decisión
correcta porque estamos en el tercer mes
de la guerra y el enemigo no ha logrado
hacer ningún avance ni alcanzar las
fronteras administrativas de la región
de lugansk así que ahora se dedican a
dispararle a todas nuestras posiciones y
todas nuestras ciudades con todas las
armas que tienen
esto incluye artillería morteros tanques
sistemas de fuego a reacción y aviones
esto sucede todos los días sin excepción
de allí que algunas de nuestras ciudades
están completamente destruidas en un 80%
cuál es la situación económica política
y militar que ha llevado a que su
provincia esté prácticamente al borde de
caer en las manos de los enemigos
[Música]
respecto a la situación económica no es
buena
todas las empresas dejaron de operar en
nuestra provincia todo se detuvo
empresas tiendas algunas instituciones
presupuestarias
nada funciona porque no tenemos ninguna
ciudad que esté segura ni siquiera hay
un lugar seguro en las ciudades que
están bajo control
in the space
los números son con todo el territorio
de la región de lugansk está siendo
bombardeado
en cuanto a la cuestión social la
situación también es terrible porque los
rusos están disparando deliberadamente
contra el sistema de suministro de gas
el suministro de agua y las
subestaciones eléctricas para que la
gente simplemente no pueda disfrutar de
ningún beneficio de la civilización
[Música]
se han roto los postes de la red
eléctrica se han roto las subestaciones
se han roto las tuberías principales
y la totalidad de la infraestructura de
áreas como compañía esquí y volcán al
alrededor de 100.000 personas se quedan
sin agua por completo centro de
infraestructuras por cuestiones de canal
en los últimos días hemos estado en
algunas partes del frente de batalla y
los mismos soldados nos han contado que
la ayuda de armas que vienen de la mano
también occidentales están ayudando a
detener ese avance de las fuerzas rusas
que tan importante es la ayuda que ha
dado occidente con estas armas
[Música]
las primeras armas están disponibles
pero todavía son cantidades
insuficientes sin embargo las armas que
están por venir nos ayudarán mucho
debido a que nos enfocamos en dos cosas
principales la primera es un arma que
nos ayudará a cerrar el aire es decir
simplemente derribaremos aviones así que
no nos podrán lanzar bombas ni misiles
se mantendrán a grandes distancias y lo
segundo es que necesitamos artillería a
largo alcance obuses esto ya se ha dicho
hay equipamiento británico equipamiento
checo y equipamiento alemán también
necesitamos mantener la artillería rusa
a distancia lo que está pasando ahora
que estamos en el tercer mes es que
nuestros hombres están en la línea de
defensa repelen todos los avances
pero la artillería rusa simplemente
dispara y destruye todas las posiciones
y lanza bombas y misiles así que a veces
no vamos muy lejos hacia atrás sino que
nos movemos hacia nuevas posiciones
lamentablemente dejamos las poblaciones
de pop asna y rubí psni allí todo está
roto no hay nada a lo que aferrarse
pero está la distancia desde la que se
llevan a cabo estos bombardeos lo que
hace imposible mantener la línea de
defensa en un solo lugar
tan pronto como consigamos los obuses
que estamos esperando en número
suficiente que pelearemos inmediatamente
al enemigo a una distancia mayor
destruiremos a la artillería y luego
podremos incluso ir al contraataque
podemos ver todas les hemos movido un
hábito controlado
días atrás visitábamos la ciudad de
severodonezk es la ciudad más importante
de su región que hoy en día está rodeada
por las fuerzas rusas como mantenerla es
posible mantenerla en poder de las
tropas ucranianas y como seguir dando
ayuda humanitaria a la gente que todavía
queda allí
bulnes
todavía disparan contra todos los
convoyes humanitarios
varias veces los rusos acordaron que
dejarían atacar para que pudieran salir
pero en realidad esto nunca pasó podemos
mostrar los autobuses que fueron
atacados mientras viajaban o
transportaban ayuda humanitaria o cuando
regresaban después de que las personas
fueran evacuadas
por eso todos los días personalmente
hago un llamado a la gente para que
vacunen a diferentes zonas y todavía lo
hacemos por cada viaje hay 50 por ciento
de posibilidades es una lotería porque
pueden disparar en cualquier momento la
última vez que estuvimos en el hospital
hablamos durante unas 23 horas con
médicos de diferentes estructuras allí
sobre temas de trabajo y durante una
hora y media hubo bombardeos fue muy
difícil pero lo logramos
iremos mañana a llevarles material
humanitario
he formado kits humanitarios es decir
que no repartimos una lata de comida a
una persona y dos a otra simplemente
repartimos kits humanitarios a la gente
[Música]
mira ahorita es una población donde se
llevan las batallas más importantes de
su región que tan importante es mantener
el control de la jurídica para que la
lucha en esa provincia no continúe y
poder defender el avance de las fuerzas
rusas en cuanto a la situación en vilo
jurídica en general por tercer día
consecutivo los rusos están tratando de
hacer un cruce de pontones y nuestras
fuerzas armadas lo están rompiendo se
hundieron tanques y se destruyeron casi
80 unidades de equipo pesado
un helicóptero fue derribado el jueves
una gran cantidad de su personal fue
sacado de combate alguien se escapó y
trató de cruzar el río pero ellos
quieren seguir intentando pero nosotros
estamos vigilantes y destruiremos todo
lo que hagan
ya tuvimos un torno bike a que los rusos
intentaron atacar decenas de veces sin
éxito cuando buscaban llegar a mi cola y
ahora tendremos un torno banca 2 pero
esta vez en vilo jurídica se van a ir de
allí pronto pero lo que queda claro es
que el ejército ruso no protege a sus
soldados
cuántas personas civiles quedan todavía
en esas poblaciones de su región y que
tanto las están ayudando para que
evacúen o incluso quieren evacuar a
jackson
si contamos todos los asentamientos que
después del 24 de febrero cuando sucedió
la invasión rusa estaban bajo el control
de ucrania estamos hablando de 350.000
personas ahora bien si contamos
simplemente lysychansk jose perdón y es
la comunidad genética y todos los
asentamientos que están en algún lugar
cercano no quedan más de 50.000 personas
y en su mayoría son personas que
realmente no quieren irse
se van solo cuando el proyectil llega a
la casa y no tienen donde vivir entonces
si se van
usted no puede estar en su provincia la
mayoría de las ciudades están en control
de los rusos o están en en contienda
cuando su vida se siente usted amenazado
como en la vida de un gobernador que no
puede estar gobernando desde su región
bueno primero que nada este es mi
trabajo en cuanto a la familia los envía
a todos al oeste de ucrania para que yo
pudiera estar tranquilo personalmente es
decir para que no me perturbe en los
pensamientos sobre mi familia y lo que
les está pasando que están en peligro y
para que estos pensamientos no
interfieran a la hora de hacer mi
trabajo
desafortunadamente realmente vivimos
donde podemos en diferentes lugares he
tenido que pasar la noche en sótanos o
en autos en el bosque en hoteles y en
algunos ex lugares de juegos semisótanos
no hay diferencia
en cuanto a la coordinación todo pasa
por mí por mis diputados porque
entendemos que somos responsables de las
personas que habitan la provincia de la
gente que se quedó aquí por eso
conectamos a todas las organizaciones de
voluntarios conectamos a todos los
conocidos conecto a todos los compañeros
de otras áreas donde no hay acción
militar directa todos nos ayudan y
tratamos de hacer lo que más podemos
nos enfocamos en tres cosas primero la
evacuación de personas
segundo la entrega de kits humanitarios
y esto es muy importante porque para las
personas que se quedan tienen que tener
agua y comida
tercero es la provisión de militares y
hospitales porque todavía tenemos un
hospital que funciona que incluso puede
estabilizar a los heridos graves y
también ayudamos a nuestros militares
con armas
en algún momento las fuerzas rusas y
moscú el gobierno de moscú se ha puesto
en contacto con usted y le ha ofrecido
rendirse que le han ofrecido
si hubo ofertas llamadas telefónicas con
el número 7
estos son operadores rusos ofrecieron
pero les contestaba siempre lo mismo
todos fueron enviados al barco ruso a la
vez es decir les dije que no
lo que todos los números que llamaban
luego a todos los que trabajaban con
nosotros les enviaron un mensaje desde
un canal de teherán con una solicitud
para ir a su lado
pero todos se respondieron unánimemente
que no no habrá cooperación
aquí el asunto es que en la
administración regional militar trabajan
personas que han estado en la guerra
desde 2014
ellos saben lo que vale la palabra y las
promesas de los rusos y nadie lo dudo
inmediatamente nos negamos los
bloqueamos y ya no se han dejado de
contactar se sale en este mes de julio y
para terminar que están en contacto está
usted con el gobierno de kiev y que tan
importante es para el gobierno central
mantener a esta provincia de lugansk
como parte de ucrania y también cuál es
su relación con occidente y también que
le dicen desde allí que tan importante
es seguir luchando por lugansk
y
quisiera agradecer a los socios
internacionales pero lo único que
realmente me molesta es que la ayuda no
llegó cuando era muy necesaria sino
tarde demasiado tarde
desgraciadamente entiendo que poca gente
creía que aguantaríamos que
sobreviviríamos sobre todo nos ayudaron
los países bálticos letonia lituania
estonia polonia y la república checa
entiendo por qué porque entienden lo que
es el gobierno ruso y que no se detienen
en ucrania
ellos seguirán por ejemplo hacia la
república checa- y hacia polonia bueno
ya han experimentado todo esto en su
tiempo y es por eso que trataron de
ayudarnos más y todavía nos ayudan hoy y
lamento que hungría se fuera hacia putin
y cambiara su libertad e independencia
por petróleo barato energía barata que
obtienen de putin
y viktor orbán en este sentido
simplemente se vendió a rusia es una
pena pero estos países son muy
solidarios
creo que todos entienden que ahora la
guerra no es sólo rusia contra ucrania
escuchamos a los propagandistas rusos
dicen que después de capturar ucrania
irán a estrasburgo y aquí están
amenazando todos con armas nucleares
explosiones bombardeos estas personas no
deberían hablar con tanta libertad y es
rusia la que realmente debería
desmilitarizarse porque cuando personas
inadecuadas con tales perversiones
mentales tienen tantas armas que pueden
destruir todo el planeta hay que
detenerla
gobernador muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros en france 24 en
español sabemos que seguridad es bien
importante y haber venido a visitarnos
se lo agradezco muchísimo